i think one of the sad things but the
realities over the past
20 25 years is the republicans have
shown themselves to be very good at
winning elections
maybe not in this particular case for
the white house but in general they win
elections
and very bad at fighting the culture
wars
and it's unfortunate because now the
democrats control
the media hollywood
academia big tech and
half the country doesn't feel
represented at all
in almost all of the information that
comes back to them publicly
what do you think about the the big tech
element then also that
you know going forward that at least
even though they did nothing i mean i
kept saying this the whole time you guys
are having these hearings
and it's great to see ted cruz who i
totally like and respect
it's great to see him grill jack but you
guys are doing it six days before an
election
and we're pretending that this is in
theater are you worried that okay trump
was sort of the last thing that was
stopping big tech from doing whatever it
might want to do
i don't know what exactly what it wants
to do but now without that threat of
we're gonna regulate you whatever it
might you know break you up stuff that i
don't particularly want them to do
uh are you worried that they're just
gonna go all in and
and silence the real resistance which
will be you know the remaining free
thinkers
yes i am worried about that i i don't
have the solution to that either i
i am worried i think one of the sad
things but the realities over the past
20 25 years is the republicans have
shown themselves to be very good at
winning elections
maybe not in this particular case for
the white house but in general they win
elections
and very bad at fighting the culture
wars
and it's unfortunate because now the
democrats control
the media hollywood um
academia big tech and
half the country doesn't feel
represented at all
in almost all of the information that
comes back to them publicly
like sports forgot to mention them so
you turn on the television and watch a
sports game
or get the news or watch the oscars
or the vmas whatever it is and
now you're getting woke ism shoved down
your neck and you're being told you're a
racist if you happen to be a republican
you like trump or even just if you're a
republican these days
and you send it a tweet that is totally
legitimate and maybe just opinionated or
a news story being reported by that
new york post censored censored censored
you know your viewpoints are you're
being told they're bad by everyone
that has control of the public
microphones and i do think it leads
people to be like
am i insane am is everything i think
awkward
i it's a problem and i think big tech is
part of the problem i really wish we
would see somebody like peter thiel you
know who you know
he's gonna have to actively create a new
twitter and a new facebook and
like there needs to be a real other
digital forum out there
that represents the other half of the
country because i just don't think
they've got much of a future on the
existing platforms well the irony is
if trump loses and then it finally gives
him the impetus to be like okay i'm
going to another platform or i'm
starting my own platform that's how the
platform will
will work right like that ultimately
would be it no you don't
you don't think that would be enough no
i think that'll be like i mean with all
due respect
sean hannity starting his own network
like you know
you know what you're going to get you're
not going to get real analysis that now
that's
no no i don't mean i don't mean you'll
get analysis i mean if trump is just
like all right i'm going i'm going to
parlor
or i'm going to locals or wherever that
it would be like everyone would go there
just to because he's still
the show in a way oh no questions yeah i
don't mean that he's going to create
some non-partisan network or something
like conservative media is well
represented in the digital world i get
that but when it comes to these main
the main platforms out there i mean
facebook is it gives a little bit more
play but they're
they're censoring a lot of stuff too but
if you could have a real and i know
there's parlor i'm on parlor but it's
just it's not what twitter is and
i don't know that it's going to be you
need a real player with a lot of money
to to create the platform and back it
and somebody with a spine of steel like
rupert murdoch to say
i don't need to be loved at the cocktail
parties i'm gonna let this be a real
forum
for mainstream conservative thought in
other words
we don't need alex jones on there okay
but like
dave rubin does not need to get censored
right and
i i that's my only thought because
you're not gonna change
jack dorsey you're not going to change
facebook you're
not going to change these big tech
organizations for whom it's like
deeply ideological they think it's the
difference between good and evil you
know it's not just about getting biden
elected it's about
silencing the rest of these racists did
you see that clip from sunny hostin on
the view
yeah unbelievable that
that embodies how they think the left
wing and i don't even mean progressives
i know you used to be one
most professors i know are totally
normal and mainstream and they don't
believe in any of this nonsense
it's the quote left with a capital l who
are
insane in the way they see the other
half of the country and sunny hostin
just
put it on display where it was like
these
at least half the country i'm not going
to say they're racists
yeah but there isn't let's see the races
but at least
half the country voted for him
notwithstanding
his racism his sex sympathism his
xenophobia his transphobia
and then another woman on the panel
sarah
i don't remember her name but she was
like how can you say that you know
people vote in their own self-interest
all the time pocket book issues and so
on
doesn't make them bad doesn't make them
racist and the response was
no because this is about we the people
and we are supposed to behave as a
collective
and do what is right it's one of those
things dave i was like oh my god i wish
so badly for the first time in my life
that i were sitting on the view
i would have loved to said to her i i
get it totally
and just out of curiosity i'm wondering
because like there's a lot of people who
really feel like
for example um abortion is murder
and it's actually killing babies and
that's wrong
and what would be right would be to ban
it outright
and if you don't support that you are on
the wrong side you're in favor of
murder and and we the people respond you
to behave as a collective
right like i could go on for you know
give me five other examples like
the outrage and by the way let's look at
the southern border you know the people
down there who have had family members
killed by people illegally coming across
with drugs and
weapons who have lost jobs to people who
are here unlawfully in the country
they have real reasons for wanting a
great border wall and for cracking down
on illegal immigration
and if you don't support it you're the
one who doesn't care about life and the
well-being of your fellow citizens and
we the people who died and made her
king of we the people right it's like do
you think that's how they think
do you think they'll ever stop that
thing like that in many ways what you
just described there
that is the thing that most
the rest of us are fighting we don't
have to make it about sunny but that
thing and it's been so successful and
and as we're talking potentially is
about to dethrone donald trump
why would they stop doing it they're not
going to
they're not going to and i agreed with
the headlines this week that said wokism
was dealt a blow during this election
because he saw
you know his numbers as you pointed out
with all these minority groups go up
people the minority groups
like it more than they used to not less
like four years of ubiquitous media
coverage telling
them he's awful racist bigot all the
stuff and that they're awful if they
like it so that didn't work oh and by
the way i mean even just today there was
a
congressman a democratic congresswoman
who was saying
uh defund the police killed us
killed us that is why we went down in
the house instead of up
and if we don't abandon that ridiculous
messaging we're going to
see a bloodbath in two years so wokism
you know the messaging was proven to be
a failure when it comes to
electoral politics but that won't deter
them that's not going to stop anything
but for the reasons i was saying it's
ideological
it makes them feel like better people
superior
um i don't know if it's their guilt if
it's just the virtue signaling makes
them feel great about themselves in bed
at night when they judge other people
and and decide they're all bad
so we're going to have to deal with it
and the people who don't believe
in this bs culture and there's so many
people in the center right who don't
either look at the harper's leather
letter look at people like andrew
sullivan who hated trump but you know
he's completely taken a stand against
this baloney
they're going to have to speak up the
people who are against it i know they're
afraid
i know you can get fired now for the
most ridiculous reasons trust me i know
um we're going to have to start taking
risks otherwise we're all going to go
down
we're going to go down together on this
war if you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations about the
media instead of non-stop yelling check
out our media playlist and if you want
to watch full interviews on a variety of
topics check out the full episode
playlist they're both right over here
and to get notified of all
future videos be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell